so i don't know exactly what's going on
with this elon thing i don't think
anyone does
some but there was an interesting thing
that happened today so elon bought the
what 9.2 percent of uh yeah twitter
he gets offered a board seat
twitter puts out that he's not going to
be on the board
and then today liked a tweet uh that
someone put out and they're like here's
the story
elon bought into twitter for free speech
the people at twitter said elon fall in
line elon said i don't want to be on the
board anymore
but also there's something on that if
you join the board you've got to sign
ndas about what they're developing what
it's all about so you're basically
hushing him
if you join the board you got to keep
quiet he doesn't want it he's going to
get he's going to get
influence and info that he could still
be free to you know that's an honor
why would he like that tweet why would
he be so sassy on the internet then
because it still makes him look good
it's still a good pr for to be like i
can't be silenced i cho i turned down
the board see because they wanted me to
play ball and i'm like the marketing of
this is that he's an advocate for free
speech and he's going to save the
platform and reinstate trump and be a
free speech advocate whatever and all of
a sudden some guy's like yeah they tried
to silence him and so he left and he's
like yeah i left that's why i didn't
like it's great for him like whether or
not this is true or not this is like
stupid influence he's still gonna yeah
but every i'm pretty sure like every
major company has like different
stipulations for their board members if
you sign up on the board it's like hey
you have to behave this way you can't do
things to drag the market share like or
to drag like the stock value things like
that
like there's certain like sec things
that are like built in that they have to
abide by and some of those things might
go against what he wants to do he's been
penalized in the past for
for tesla
yeah what was the smoking on rogan right
i'm pretty sure no it was something that
just caused fluctuations in the price
huh
yeah i don't know that's interesting
that's interesting
so then what do you think this whole
thing was he must have known that he's
not an idiot he has publicly traded
companies i'm assuming he went into the
negotiation being like oh yeah i'll be
able to tell him like no i don't want to
abide by these specific stipulations and
they're like well no you have to assume
they got into a negotiation this is so
normal for all these companies then he
would know that's normal and then he
that he wasn't going to be able to get
around it unless he can negotiate his
way around because now he's the biggest
shareholder on twitter yeah he probably
thought you'd be able to get around it
mostly and they just said nah now why
can they say nah if he's the biggest
shareholder because all the board
members own shares bigger than him uh so
together he owns their collective
plurality but not the majority ah
so their collective shares give them
more influence on him right and he
probably thought that some of them were
going to come on board with what he
wanted to do and they were like nah
we're not about that life
i'm assuming no one knows
it's really funny that i'll go out no i
didn't know it's really funny the
position that elon's in where we're just
like uh you're captain savior and you
can just save anything yeah you know
it's like oh the national debt just let
elon handle it like we just observe him
as this really smart guy and that he can
solve any problem and twitter free
speech he's going to figure it out here
are all his ideas everybody gets a blue
check more than anybody i've ever seen
remember when he bought bitcoin and the
price [ __ ] skyrocketed yeah and then
he sold and the price [ __ ] plummeted
so what does that say about us that like
once you convince us that you're more
intelligent that we will follow you
blindly i think there's a threshold for
genius that we're just like this guy's
got it he's got it all figured out and
track record mostly track record and i
think the distance between
the result that you want and just him
it's like oh
he's so powerful that if he's convincing
us that that's a that's a path that's a
new tech versus going through the
government and all the steps there you
can trust what he's getting a little bit
more yeah yeah that's interesting yeah
you gotta chill on his track record he's
starting to take some elves talk to me
he still where's that highway that was
supposed to be in l.a oh the tunnel
what about the internet that was
supposed to be in uh [ __ ] russia and
ukraine yeah
i don't think i don't hear anybody
talking about it i don't hear it helping
people they're still we forget we yeah
we forget videos that are being able to
like come out of those areas that's the
biggest problem as long as his w shine
brighter than his elves he'll be that's
true
that's the thing like we're bought in
like [ __ ] are invested in tesla
which is an investment in elon literally
invested that that's trump it doesn't
matter how many businesses go under like
he ran for president he won like yeah he
took on the media he won like shine the
light on your w's man
i feel it's like he has the kanye effect
where it's like all right we bought into
kanye so everything he does we'll pay
attention to it but if you start [ __ ]
up then we're gonna start looking at
your other stuff like hey wait these
clothes are just you just remix some
clothes put some holes in it damn but
we're still paying for the clothes no
there was a time where it was starting
to hurt like people weren't buying
yeezys as much or whatever and then he
kind of bounced back
yeah yeah that's what i'm saying it's
like and i'll even say this with the
tesla [ __ ] like everybody that gets a
tesla says the same thing to me oh my
god you gotta get tesla tesla is the
[ __ ] best car ever you guys car tesla
you said the same thing
best car ever like literally everyone
says my friend my friend just got one i
think he got you got the one that got
like the uh spaceship steering wheel
the plaid or whatever like that he's
like oh you got to do it it's so fast
like
to me and again when i'm in it i'm like
oh this is nice it's fun it's kind of
comfortable it's minimalist but the
design is really good but like
that to me the car is not that
impressive visibly like i like
aesthetic with a car because i don't
really know much about cars so i love
like the old classics right because i'm
like oh this this took place in a time
where like they didn't have to worry
about like miles per gallon and then
have all these limitations it was just
hey just make the prettiest [ __ ]
thing in the world right so that's
something that i really appreciate i i
don't think that they're the most
beautiful car i never thought it was as
i thought it looked good i don't find it
the most beautiful car but it was the
first especially if it's the first
electric you've ever driven you're not
prepared for how smooth it is and then
all of a sudden you start driving a car
where it's like yo this is like i'm
driving on [ __ ] pillows like i barely
feel the road and then you're just
immediately like i've never driven
anything like this it blows your mind i
also i was arriving experience yeah and
you're not usually the driver i was just
about to say that the passenger
experience you guys grew up driving yeah
so driving means something to you and
you attach yourself to like not only
things you love about it but things you
hate about it and it seems to have
solved the problems that you guys have
with driving absolutely
i grew up on a subway so all cars are
kind of like the same yeah and oh yeah
this one is a little bit better this
steering is a little bit different over
here but it's not that big of a deal
it doesn't affect my life in the same
way that for you guys a car with like
shitty steering i don't even understand
shitty steering
yeah be even after being in new york for
10 years the idea of having a nice car
just almost meant nothing to me once i
got the tesla i was like oh this is
great this drive is great has its flaws
but it drives great but it's not as
important as it is if you're like a guy
who commutes to work for an hour every
day the car is like the sneaker of
florida yes it is like when you're in
florida like you got to have the nice
car because that's your sneaker and the
sneakers don't matter you work because
yeah most people see your car and
sneaker culture made sense to me when i
came to new york because i was like oh
you walk everywhere and you don't have a
car so the only way i can flex is this
but like all these things make sense
yeah yeah people having like these
rednecks of floor with their lifted
trucks or whatever like that's a flex
like that's the flex i drive everywhere
i pull up in the parking lot you see
this [ __ ] i got the biggest truck with
the biggest thing and the loudest horn
in the whatever like you see me get into
it stupid it's a change yeah it sounds
stupid but like they're also looking at
some of the things that we would do in
new york and be like oh that's
absolutely ridiculous thousand dollars
on shoes you got how many pairs
and then in new york you're like oh you
also walk through them very quickly you
wear a sneaker the [ __ ] out after eight
months in new york in the suburbs a
sneaker can last you five years you
don't walk like that
so new york you have to have a rotation
of fresh sneakers it's the only way to
flex and i'm gonna run through these
[ __ ] quickly
all you got in the suburbs is cars yeah
they're all things basically you're
seeing the taxis exist right now there's
like a revel that has the tesla taxis i
think like their goal is also you see
the future movies where all the cars are
kind of the same where you won't once
your car drops you off at work your
self-driving car is driving around
picking up other people
making money or you have a share in a
car and they're all self-driving so it's
like it looks good enough for all of
that in mass and this individualized
like oh this car is mine and this is my
taste like that's kind of out the window
like how people aren't like owning as
much as or it's not as important to just
own and this is me this is my
personality exactly it's like it's a
very nice car
for a big population
i wonder about this in the future when
cars are self-driving right is right now
bmw ultimate driving machine is it the
future just going to be if you own a car
it's all about the passenger experience
like are the [ __ ] seats are super
comfortable and you've got x number of
tvs and you can recline this [ __ ] all
the way back as opposed to the engine
and the horsepower it's just gonna be
what allows me and my friends to ride in
the comfiest fashion that's the car that
costs the most money hmm
that's luxury that's what i'm assuming
because a porsche ain't gonna do [ __ ]
nothing when it's self-driving yeah
that's a waste of everything it's
completely inconvenient it's me and one
other person sitting mad low [ __ ] wants
this bucket seat it's gonna all depend
on like okay you're in la you're in
traffic hour hour and a half super lux
in the back seat but in that bit doesn't
matter
just get me here 10 minute drive that's
interesting like if the assumption is
we'll have more people and more people
equals more cars
you should plan
the design of the car around traffic
if you can't solve the
the traffic problem right if you can't
make a four-lane highway eight lanes or
whatever the other complications are so
solve the problem of traffic by just
making that drive more bearable yeah you
can do work while you're doing it to
commute also traffic will be mitigated
well you know who does that now yeah
once the internet of things exists their
traffic is almost non-existent that's
what they say i don't know if i
necessarily believe that if all the
people have to go to work at the same
time like you're still gonna have cars
but if there's
fewer cars and people are able to like
even carpool or go like 300 miles an
hour on the highway oh that's right that
could be faster okay so there could be
other things
on the self-driving car thing i did
think was interesting that elon came out
and said oh if you have a tesla you can
sign it up for the program to drive
other people around while you're not
using it yeah that's the whole that's
the whole idea so he's basically like
you own a tesla you go to work and your
car is sitting there for eight hours let
it drive people around and then you'll
get paid instead of just having your car
sit there mm-hmm
exactly that's a great
where can that work
what do you mean it'll work in cities
but but it's not now
soon it's illegal self-driving is
illegal
some small cities are going to be the
pilot program to be like all right let
it work in this city
my understanding was it wasn't good
enough like it doesn't understand red
lights and stuff wheezy got a tesla in
la and she has full self driving
her she's in the beta and it
makes turns for you like it's crazy
stops at red lights stops at the red
light stops at stop signs
i think they got that figured out
yeah the red light drops how do they
figure out the red light
i think
they got that it's all it's my car
figured out it's not the thing that's
going to be tapped into like the
lighting grid no just the [ __ ] camera
is able to tell which one's red which
one's green
but what if the sun
is blasting like eight cameras on the
cars the sun is blasting light on the uh
that's about the internet of things can
i just make the point can i just make a
point you [ __ ] idiot what if the sun
is blasting light on the green part
of the light right you don't think elon
musk was like oh yeah there might be the
sun yeah we gotta think about it well
that's the big issue right is that the
the the camera picks up shadows and
that's what some of the crashes yeah the
thing on your side the sun reflected on
a white truck and so it blinded it but
again you're talking about there's
issues here but yes but billions and
billions of pieces of data it's able to
analyze and millions of driving hours i
guarantee you if you put that up to like
the normal driving record of a 16 year
old or anyone else it's that much safer
but i don't think people are ready to be
killed by robotic cars yeah like that
just
it's different like right if there was a
person there we were making a left turn
um going
a three-lane street
and so it actually waited for traffic to
pass for a clear opening and it made the
turn by itself
yeah that [ __ ] was was there a light
was it was it nighttime
it was kind of sunny it was sunny it was
kind of coming in like that if the sun
is blasting at that red light that
yellow light and that green light are
the same light yeah
there's no way they could possibly tell
it's gotta plug into the grid i think
it's plugged into the city's grid bro if
it's plugged into the grid then it makes
perfect sense it's got google maps i'm
sure it is yeah yeah that makes perfect
sense plug it into the grid why would
you try to predict what the light is
when this is i assume that's what it is
i think it has
what if some [ __ ] guy goes up and
tapes the light
this happens in new york all the time
they put a middle finger on the stop
sign then everyone will go through it
say again how does that make it better
or worse than a human we have eyes dummy
yeah the car is able to see when there's
other cars what do you mean if a car is
merging into the lane the car will move
out of the way we're talking about the
light mode
it's not operating how it should they're
gonna the car's gonna stop that i
thought self-driving would always be
internet of things like every [ __ ]
everybody
everybody stopped here's the stop what
is it called a stop light yeah yeah yeah
a traffic light a traffic light here's a
traffic light okay yeah red green yellow
i think that's what it is okay right
but i'm all bored now okay
red green yellow yeah okay
sun blasting yeah how bright blaster
super bright okay they try to put those
little canopies on top they try to put
the little
sometimes the angle is too crazy right
all these are perfectly lit it's golden
eyes
exactly okay yellow lit yeah green lit
red lit that's confusing tesla can't
tell which one it is what's it gonna do
what is it gonna [ __ ] do martin yeah
has no clue it's
what are you gonna do though what are
you gonna do if you're driving and all
of them are lit up because i'm not a
[ __ ] robot mark but what are you
gonna tell which one's a little more lit
wow if the sun's hitting it you guys
could always tell him
the human instinct you just said it was
produced he's not a captain humanist
it's not a human instinct
let's say for example i'll give you
another situation [ __ ]
there's a big ass truck blocking some of
that light oh no but it's bouncing off
the top of the
gonna go off the truck just the red is
lit right
green yellow completely covered even
though it's a [ __ ] green light oh no
then what happens you get in a crash
people die cause what are you gonna do
when you're driving red yellow green
buddy i think yeah yeah
yeah looking at the
look at the lights even
what am i gonna do what if you're first
in line mark what do you do then you're
first in line okay
okay
what you said you're gonna look at all
the other cars see what they do you
can't so you're first right now the car
chimes when it the light changes green
because it knows that we don't say we
all know we're looking at our phone and
so the car is like yo wake up they're
like our nose better than you the
clown's looking at it